what's going on guys my name is David
tomich I'm a registered architect here
in Western Australia and today it's part
two of the completely free arcade course
that progressed with our course today we
are going to be exploring the site mesh
and modeling in archicad 26. now I'll
point out one I'm still sick so I do
apologize for that two site modeling and
everything that I show in arcad 26 is
convertible across all archicads
basically the new ones that come out are
CAD 23 4-5 you name it it's pretty much
all exactly the same thing
so what you want to do is if you have a
DWG available from feature surveyor drag
and drop that into your project right
now I'll quickly drag one in and get rid
of any confidential information okay so
now we've dragged DWG in from the
surveyor and sometimes it comes in color
sometimes come from black and white it
really depends on the surveyor itself if
you don't have one this isn't going to
be too critical for this stage of the
actual works and you can basically still
follow along the same steps and
procedures this just gives us a bit more
of a bounding box to design and work
with so I've dragged it in first of all
and it is not to scale at all what we
want to do is first select the whole
thing zoom in press command K to
activate our resize tool press OK and
then find a dimension so for example
here 19.5 is our front boundary so what
I'm going to do is zoom in to one
section
come all the way across by zooming in
and out using my scroll wheel click on
the second point and then you'll see the
line starts to extend but nothing
happens what we want to do is type 19
500 because this is in millimeters not
meters and then press enter if we now
zoom out our feature survey is
completely to scale in both formats
please take note that with archicad you
can only scale in both directions at
once you can't scale just in One
Direction so if it isn't formatted
correctly if it's Shrunk the wrong way
you're going to have a bad time now that
we have our site to scale what I'm going
to do is select all of these markers for
the sections and elevations that are
basically in our way now by holding
shift and clicking on each of them
individually next I'm going to press
command or control x d depending on
which system you're on to move them out
of the way
now before we start using our mesh tool
over here we want to make sure that our
site is set up correctly so we don't
have any problems later on for this
project if you're looking at it 6.4 6.2
your rough ground level for the house or
whatever you design on this would be
anywhere from 6.4 to 6.3 if you're
building on natural ground so let's say
we're going to use 6.4 as our floor
level and then basically fill some more
sand in front of it what we need to do
is come up to archicad go down to
project preferences and then scroll down
to reference levels when a little pop-up
opens you're going to see project zero
elevation zero first reference level is
zero second reference level zero and all
the same
what you want to do is actually change
the first reference level so we want to
change that to minus
6400 and press enter y will all make
sense in just a little minute now it's
time to come across to our mesh tool and
start using this I'm going to make sure
you get into very good best practices
from the start in arcad first thing you
want to do is make sure you're looking
at your layers what layer is this on
where is it showing and why mesh site is
automatically default to mesh site which
is perfectly fine it isn't visible so as
you can see the eye is crossed out and
gone because we're on the wrong view map
as you can see we're on the ground floor
presentation so obviously they don't
really care too much about the site now
I have skipped a step to be completely
honest and that was by not putting this
feature survey on the right level so
let's quickly just select all of the
feature survey and change the layer
to cite context and press ok now if we
double click on our site plan increase
the scale from 1 200 to 1 to 100 zoom
out a little bit press our settings get
our current window settings as discussed
in part one we can now come to our mesh
tool see that our mesh site is activated
and then we can choose one of our four
objects here we can go from polygonal we
can go rectangle we can go rotate a
rectangle etc for this we simply want to
go for the polygonal and click around
our boundary so zooming in making sure
we're selecting just that green line
following the procedure and process all
the way around clicking once more at the
very end now what you'll see is if I
zoom in you'll see the difference of
each line thickness and it gets a little
bit messy in my opinion so personally
what I like to do is come up to view go
on-screen view options and then untick
true line weight so if I untick that it
is much cleaner much nicer they are all
the consistently same pen weight and
I'll only turn that back on when I need
to cross check pin weights now I have a
lot of experience with the pen weights I
know which ones to use which ones not to
use so this isn't always recommended for
beginners but if you do want to change
it it is up there just true line weight
on and off now if we click in the middle
of our site it will highlight that mesh
immediately and if I right click show
all in 3D
double-click my scroll wheel it will
Center my site and you'll see amazingly
it's created a 3D site grass on top
Earth down below and we have a big
rectangle nothing special nothing too
fancy but obviously we need to make this
proper and we need to make it look
exactly like the site itself so let's
come back to our site plan select the
mesh go back to our mesh tool making
sure that we are on the polygonal tool
because this doesn't work very well
otherwise holding your spacebar allows
you to use the magic wand tool the magic
wand tool can be used in a number of
ways and we'll discuss more ways as we
progress through the course but for this
use case we're basically going to hover
over one of these contour lines click OK
and click ok so then we're going to
repeat that for every contour line on
this feature survey luckily there isn't
too many there is only a couple so now
what that's going to do is basically
create hotspots and nodes that we can
adjust the levels and Heights of this
mesh
so by clicking on it you'll see hundreds
of them by going back to 3D you'll see
the contour lines drawn in in 3D as well
and hotspots available
you simply want to mess around with it
in 3D you can select any of the hot
spots look for the little pop-up toolbar
select the little Z Arrow which is
Elevate mesh point and you can drag it
Up drag it down do whatever you want and
adjust the mesh accordingly so I'm going
to press Ctrl command Z or Zed however
you like it undo that command come back
to our site plan select our mesh zoom in
a little bit understand that this corner
is
5.94 so I'm going to select the corner
and do the same and instead of going to
mesh reference plane I'm going to go to
First reference level which we changed a
moment ago
you see that we had to go minus to be
able to actually get this in positive
territory in archicad
so 6400 is our zero zero ground level
but we want to adjust this to 5940 press
Ok We're going to repeat the same steps
for all four corners because they're
quite simple and then we don't really
want to go through each individual
little node and change them all to six
thousand six thousand two hundred
because that would just drive us all
crazy so we are going to select one we
are going to change that back to First
mesh level we'll simply type in 6000 and
make sure we select apply to all and
press ok I'm going to repeat the same
process for the remaining Contours and
then when we're done we can come back
into our 3D site
now zooming around by holding shift and
clicking the scroll wheel we can see our
site is relatively flat yes absolutely
but there is a slight fall from the back
left corner over here to the bottom
right hand corner over here now this is
just our existing sight mesh if we come
back to our site plan itself you'll see
we also have a little bit of an extended
Verge here we have the curb from the
road and then we have the road itself
now obviously I know this site well I
have the PDF information which has a bit
more confidential data on it to tell me
that this is the road this is The Verge
Etc so I'm making some informed
decisions here at the same time I know
that these three lines are services to
the property for example this I know is
water because it is labeled as water
this is also water and the last one is
gas now if you wanted to change them to
different colors just so you can
delineate what is what you can quickly
go through change the colors so you know
you've got water most likely sewer and
most likely gas what we want to do is
model bit of our context as well so that
when we do three these later down the
track we have a little bit modeled we
know what's going on so by holding our
option button we can activate our
eyedropper tool select our mesh click
once create our extended mesh to the
curb and then finish off our rectangle
coming back into 3D
you see it's created a new flat mesh
following the same principles so back
into our site plan simply follow those
steps adjust our Corners accordingly and
you see it's updated to reflect that now
there are also contour lines here if we
wish to go to that extent so same system
hold the space bar click click click and
update the nodes and there we go that is
quickly tying back in so it looks very
seamless and clean we can repeat that
same process for the curb and the road
and next we'll start talking about
materiality in our site mesh now that
we've modeled our curb and our road
you're going to see one thing different
about the road first of all the road is
just a millimeter thick it has no
context to it underneath which is a
little bit strange compared to what
we've drawn before especially if we look
up the top here where it says 1 000
millimeters deep exactly the same as all
of these now arcad will show you this
exact scenario every single time it if
your Falls across the mesh you've
created are greater than one meter so if
you do need to see the Earth underneath
whatever reason simply increase that
depth and it will automatically create
something for you so by adjusting that
one thousand to three thousand we've
managed to get our Earth back now
obviously this site isn't all grass we
know the roads aren't grass we know the
curbs aren't grass so let's start with
our road if we press command T to open
up our settings we're going to see all
of the mesh settings now I'll run
through these relatively quickly to give
you an in-depth understanding of what
they are first of all we already spoke
about this the 3000 indicates the depth
of the mesh the zero indicates it's
offset from this home story The Home
story in this instance is ground we'll
talk about these home stories in the
next part of this tutorial our project
zero is zero which if we change to First
reference is six four and then we have
our actual composition types if we
select soil you can change change it to
any other composition you do want to
make sure this is relatively consistent
to the products you're using because it
will help you as you dive deeper so the
more good habits you pick up now the
more you will thank yourself in the
future I'm happy to leave it as soil for
now it's not too big of a deal I won't
talk about pens and line weights and
correct combinations and because there
are so many viewers from around the
world there are a number of different
combinations of how this can be set up
yes there is a generic standard that
everybody should be using does everybody
do that absolutely not arcad by default
does provide you with what they should
be so if you scroll across you can see
that it's changing its name up the top
here and the more you spend on here
you'll recognize what pen they should be
and what line weights they should be
archicad is again pretty good it will
automatically change these to what they
should be so 153 is already set up by
default as Earth cut lines which is
exactly what we're looking for I'll come
back to this model section in just a
minute however this classification
section down below is going to be really
important when you're creating schedules
especially for doors and windows so make
sure it's always in the right
classification your IDs are for your ID
markers and tags which allow you
basically to model appropriately and
then provide information back linked
accordingly you can go through all of
these import update and correctly
address them but these are some pretty
substantial and very Advanced Techniques
in archicad so for this course we will
not be going in to anything of this
depth and magnitude now you see three
images here on the side the top surface
the side surface and the bottom surface
the top surface is overridden which
means we can automatically change
whatever we want that surface to be if I
untick it press OK it will change it
back to soil for the very simple reason
command or control T to open this back
up it is defined as soil and that has
its own textures built in to the model
material so by coming back to our
topsoil selecting grass we can come and
change this to whatever we want if you
start typing in Asphalt you'll get
asphalt dark and asphalt light asphalt
light perfectly fine pressing OK we can
see that automatically change to a road
if we wanted to repeat that same step
for the curb and make sure the curb was
dark we could do that as well and then
we have a light Road a dark curb I'm
pretty certain this will remain as grass
or some sort of landscaping but the site
as mesh existing will definitely not be
grass it will be turned and flipped and
rotated dug everything in between so
it's most likely going to be the sand of
some sort sand beige perfectly fine
press OK and there you go we now have
four different textures on our mesh one
for the road one for the curb one for
the verge of being grass and of course
our actual site as well if you wanted to
go ahead and model all of the
neighboring sides extend the road and
the curbs across put some fences in you
absolutely could with the feature survey
information you even have details of the
houses next door where their pools are
you could jump on Google Maps document
it and be able to import it in to your
3D renders at the very end however for
the purposes of this tutorial we're
going to focus on just this site and
just the mesh itself One Last Thing
Before we wrap this tutorial off we're
going to press command L and open up our
layers tool you're going to see that we
have a site mesh but we only have really
one site mesh what happens when you
start cutting filling digging moving and
changing the actual parameters of the
site well what I'm going to do is Select
our mesh site come down to rename and go
existing now what I'm going to do is
actually create a new layer as well it
won't let me create a new layout whilst
I'm searching so I'm going to exit out
of that tap new go mesh Dash site post
click off it and then make sure that I
select our plan site scroll down
activate the eye and update our layer
combination pressing ok now when we come
back into our site plan I can hold my
option button grab my eyedropper tool
change my mesh layer from existing to
proposed click Once on This 6-4 contour
line and go to our end and finish off at
the top of our six four contour line
circle around it finish off our shape
and our texture what I now want to do is
select one of the end nodes go to our
subtract from polygon and hold the
spacebar to subtract and cut out all of
these extras which we don't need because
they're outside of our six four and
there we go now our mesh is perfectly
cut into that six four parameter I do
still want to slope it a little bit I
don't want it to just bank at 6 4 all
the way and have a big 200 300 mil Gap
here so what I'm going to do is
introduce a couple spare nodes over here
make sure these back ones are 6 4 and
then I'll adjust just these two corners
in 3D so coming back to 3D you can see
our proposed site mesh there I'm simply
going to drag that one down and drag
that one down to match our mesh so now
we have a relatively flat site at six
four that we can utilize for the
purposes of design good practice
honestly would be just to put this 6'4
mesh underneath the house and allow the
house to step down to six four so that
we didn't have to retain any of these
sides however we're just assuming that
there's an endless budget we can retain
quite easily we can Bank we have no
issues with her neighbors anyway that's
all for me today guys thank you so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed the
video if you did make sure you smash
that subscribe button down below and to
the side of me you'll see the complete
course which I'll add to weekly but like
I said that is all for me so I'll see
you next Monday